bonjour à tous bienvenue sur votre
chaîne de vulgarisation politique
la chaîne qui vous explique en quelques
minutes les instances politiques
françaises aujourd'hui on va parler des
élections législatives cette année au
mois de juin se déroulent les élections
législatives ce sont les élections qui
permet d'élire les membres de
l'assemblée nationale les députés alors
pour les détails je vous invite à
regarder les trois vidéos qu'on a déjà
fait sur le parlement les députés et les
sénateurs
mais rapidement le pouvoir législatif en
france est détenu par le parlement le
parlement français possède deux chambres
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat les
sénateurs du sénat donc sont élus de
moitié tous les trois ans au suffrage
universel indirect
et il ne nous concerne pas pour cette
vidéo les députés eux de l'assemblée
nationale sont élus tous les cinq ans au
suffrage universel direct lors des
élections législatives
c'est le sujet de la vidéo
le rôle des députés est divisé en deux
grandes parties contre les gouvernements
et faire des eaux leurs outils pour
contrôler les gouvernements sont par
exemple les questions orales ou écrites
les motions de censure des commission
denquête le vote de confiance concernant
la fabrication des lois je vous invite à
regarder d'autres vidéos sur une loi
mais sinon les députés doivent créer
déposé examiné modifié et vos éléments
les députés ont aussi d'autres tâches
bien sûr comme voter le budget de l'état
votée des modifications de la
constitution autorise et les
déclarations de guerre autorisé la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence et
l'état de siège
concernant les règles de l'élection à
proprement dit au premier tour un
candidat sera élu s'il arrive à
recueillir la majorité absolue des
suffrages exprimés représentant au moins
25 % des électeurs inscrits
ça veut dire que s'il ya 100 électeurs
inscrits et que 50 personnes votent
réellement il sera élu au premier tour
s'il a la majorité de ces cinquante
suffrages et donc 26 votes
par contre si seulement 30 personnes
votent et qu'il obtient 20 voix il ne
sera pas élu au premier tour
car bien que ce soit la majorité des
votes ça ne couvre pas le minimum des 25
% d'électeurs inscrits si personne
n'était lui au premier tour
il existe alors deux possibilités pour
le second tour
dans un premier cas au moins deux
candidats ont obtenu un minimum de 12
25% des suffrages des électeurs inscrits
et donc tous ces candidats peuvent se
présenter au second tour dans un
deuxième cas
un seul aucun des candidats n'a obtenu
12 à 2 5% des suffrages des électeurs
inscrits et donc seuls les deux
candidats avec le plus de suffrages
peuvent se présenter au second tour
au second tour le candidat qui obtient
le plus de suffrages est élu peu importe
si cela représente la majorité des
inscrits ou non et députés sont élus
dans une circonscription mais
représentent la nation toute entière
c'est pour ça qu'il n'est pas cohérent
d'attendre de son député d'augmenter le
nombre de crèches de nettoyer les rues
d'enlever les feuilles qui tombent ou
trouver à chacun en logements dans la
circonscription
l'enjeu n'est pas locale il est national
et si on voit un niveau local c'est
juste pour éviter que tous les députés
viennent des grandes villes de métropole
et pour qu'il représente toute la france
y compris notre mère et les français de
l'étranger
en plus depuis 2017 les députés ne
peuvent plus cumuler leur mandat
parlementaire avec une fonction
exécutive locale donc fini le fameux
cumul député-maire et c'est pour cette
raison que de nombreux députés ne se
représentent pas cette année préférant
leur statut de mère à celui de député
et ça veut dire que l'assemblée
nationale aura plein de nouveaux visages
le but du député est de conseiller et
d'aider le gouvernement à faire son
travail
s'il est dans la majorité et au
contraire s'y est dans l'opposition
son travail est d'éviter que le
gouvernement agissent d'une façon qui ne
lui convient pas ansa le rôle du député
est essentielle à la démocratie
les français pensent souvent qu'une fois
le président élu le travail est fait et
que l'élection des députés n'est qu'un
détail
alors qu'en fait c'est tout le contraire
une fois le président élu il doit former
un gouvernement en nommant son premier
ministre et ses ministres
le choix des ministres se fait parmi les
membres de la majorité parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale
le fait que le gouvernement vienne de la
majorité parlementaire n'est pas une
obligation d'un point de vue de la loi
mais c'est une pratique très respectée
car le gouvernement est responsable
devant le parlement
d'ailleurs après leur nomination les
gouvernements se mettent toujours leur
programme politique à un vote de
confiance au parlement
et pour rappel le pouvoir exécutif en
france est divisée en deux parties
il ya d'un côté le président et de
l'autre le gouvernement
donc les membres de la majorité
parlementaire même après la nomination
du gouvernement le parlement continue de
garder un oeil sur le gouvernement
par exemple si le premier ministre veut
utiliser l'alinéa 3 de l'article 49 de
la constitution
oui je parlais 49 3
et bien si 58 députés créé une motion de
censure et qu'elle est adoptée donc voté
par la majorité de l'assemblée nationale
eh bien le gouvernement doit
démissionner concernant les lois peu
importe qu'une loi c'est une proposition
faite par des parlementaires ou un
projet déposé par le gouvernement
même issue d'une directive européenne
ils peuvent empêcher le vote de cette
loi si elle ne leur convient pas le
président de l'assemblée élue par les
députés est lui aussi une personne super
importante
c'est le quatrième homme de l'état il
peut par exemple saisir le conseil
constitutionnel et on nomme trois
membres
c'est le président de la haute cour qui
sert à juger le président de la
république et du congrès qui est la
réunion de l'assemblée nationale et du
sénat
et ce n'est plus toute petite partie de
son pouvoir
nous ferons plus tard d'autres vidéos
pour parler des présidents du parlement
pour résumer les députés ensemble ont un
énorme pouvoir
voter aux législatives c'est aussi
l'occasion de donner une importance
nationale à certaines idées à certains
modes de vie défendu par des petits
partis on peut citer par exemple le
parti pirate qui défend le partage de la
culture de l'information
le parti animalistes qui défend la
question animale
on peut enfin si telle initiative ma
voix qui souhaitent proposer des députés
tirés au sort qui voteront selon une
consultation citoyenne sur internet
tout ça pour vous dire à aller voter aux
législatives
maintenant vous savez qu'il ne faut pas
sous-estimer cette élection et que tout
n'est pas joué au deuxième tour des
présidentielles
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à liker et à la commenter
suivez nous sur les réseaux sociaux et à
très bientôt
[Musique]
et